yeah i'm like tom negotiating with these
guys for a podcast to do a podcast a
true crime podcast
you already have a true crime podcast no
no like one that's like
heavily um you know produced like a
one that's on you know like um wandery
or you know
oh like like a serial type exactly music
and suspense of course and interviews
but you know
right right right who are you
negotiating with
um big tech no no it's uh
a little bit everywhere productions
they're out of la
and i've been talking to these talking
to the guys and they're they're super
cool there's this guy dan and
we so did you sign a shopping agreement
no we haven't done it we've just been
going back and forth with
with the lo with his their lawyers right
now you know how many [ __ ] i've
talked to in the past
month who are who talk tell me about
shopping agreements they're in
oh yeah i got a shopping agreement that
means nothing like i got a shopping
agreement yeah i'm gonna quit my job
next week i got a shopping agreement
i'm going to be on netflix don't quit
your job buddy my literary agent
called me or sent me an email then we
talked on the phone
um was it yesterday i think was
yesterday and he was like look i've got
these guys
they produce this they produce that they
wanna they they want to uh
option the rights to your story and i
was like wait my personal story and
they're like yeah you're a personal
story they're this they've got a
a netflix thing and netflix and i'm like
uh-huh uh-huh uh-huh
and you know i could tell he he was like
i didn't could tell i wasn't
you know all excited about it because
because i've been through it
over and over it's like i've
i talked to maybe three or four of these
people a month and it's always the same
thing
we're ready to go we have a production
company we've got to deal with these
people and these people
we're gonna these people are in with
this we have a first look deal with sony
we've got a first look deal with this so
and so we've produced this people
you can look at my ibm or imb or
whatever the hell that thing is you know
you know you can imdb imdb and you know
and
you're right it does look pretty good by
the way anybody can put one of those up
but you know yeah it looks
it looks good you they tell how they're
connected with all these different
things and it's huge and it's massive
and we're ready to go
i wouldn't be shocked if we weren't in
production within 90 days
we've got a meeting scheduled next week
we're ready to go we just need to go
ahead and sign this up
sign the option and we'll go ahead and
get get going and
and and yeah i notice your option says
18 months with an extra six months
automatic extension if you need it right
right well yeah that's standard
actually it's really not standard um and
and well i mean obviously we need that
why do you need that you have a meeting
next week
you would be would be shocked if we
weren't in production in 90 days
why am i signing an 18-month agreement
well that's just the standard it's not
standard stop saying it's standard
there's no standard that's not standard
and but they are all they are it's
always 18 months with an extra three
months or 18 months with an extra nine
months
eight teams with six likes it's always
there trying to get 18 months but what
they really do is this
you sign one you sign one you sign
you've got a true crime story about
fraud you've got one about
murder this guy's had a uh some crappy
novel that came out but it's an
interesting kind of story and
so we've got an option agreement with
him for 18 months and they put them on
the shelf
and then when they get the netflix
meeting they go in and they pitch
this right it well they can say we're
pitching shark in the housing pool and
they're like man that's amazing
what else do you have well we also have
this so you're one of a bunch of people
that they've got but they're not really
pushing just you
yeah they make it sound like like it's a
movie about you right what
are you talking about they're already
talking they're already talking to cast
members right
they're not sure who's going to play you
is it going to be so-and-so or so and so
we're it's all
our whole team is ready to go but i need
18 months
you know we're talking about a 40
million movie here really yeah but you
can't give me
20 grand for my option yeah they sell
you they like to sell you this pipe
dream like that you're gonna get some
crazy deal and you're something special
but in reality it's not it's really like
just like the biggest scam
brokers they're all just brokers they're
hoping to get you
locked in so they can sell you notice
it's like flipping contracts for for
real estate
that's exactly what it is sign them up
for 90 days and then run around and try
and sell the property so you can make
the difference and that's all they're
doing
but it's like you know look you know
what you're not gonna con me
okay this is not how this works okay you
don't screw me
right screw you over that's how this
works
like what are you doing what are you
thinking it's not going to happen
and and so it's so funny because i have
signed a few options
but they've always been like 60 day or
sorry like 90 days or
six months yeah you can negotiate right
and then they're always cutouts
so i do this cut out and that kind of by
the time it's all the way down it's like
look you've got like you have six months
to get me a deal
to be the host of a show that talks
about
true crime anything else is is off the
table
and they're just like well what if wait
a minute if you come in there some
some slight alteration obviously we'll
we'll discuss it at that time i mean i'm
not stupid
what if we get to the end of the six
months so you're telling me you're
negotiating a multi-million deal and at
the end of six months i go up you're
hit come on man i'm not gonna do that
obviously you're in there got no
negotiations what am i gonna say stop
talking to him talk to me now
come on it's unprofessional obviously
i'm gonna give you an extension
you know you have to trust me those
[ __ ] are greedy bro they want
to lock you up
absolutely and this is the thing too
they they keep saying well you're going
to have to trust me no no
you're going to have to trust me like if
you want me to trust you to represent me
you're going to have to trust that i'll
give you the extension and you're gonna
have to trust that eight
you know in 18 months is too much like
stop you know most people get so excited
they just signed and then three months
later they're calling the guys not
responding to their calls
maybe 16 months later they call you up
and go
look we pitched your story the other day
and you're going who's this
yeah you know oh remember you saw in the
d
yeah bro i've left like 16 20 messages
i've been real busy for a year
you know it's just ridiculous man i mean
you know they're such scumbags that's
such a joke man they're right so
i know that's why you're so [ __ ]
slimy and they're so [ __ ] they're all
liars and they're all
remember the first time we went we went
to like um the first night i did
uh did concrete and we went to um waffle
house
oh he was [ __ ] he i listen after
listening to him for 30 minutes hates
hollywood like she hates the
establishment
well i'm trying to get a true crime
poncho this is what you're telling me
i'm telling you this and he's like
[ __ ] them man they're scumbags they're
this they're that i'm thinking like
i didn't say it that was oh you were go
you were going pretty bad maybe not
scumbags
you were you were like you were like nah
man listen you need to just do it forget
them
then they're going to tell you this and
tell you this you need to do it your way
and i'm sitting there well you can do it
you can do it but don't
wait for them don't wait for it right do
your [ __ ] because those [ __ ]
are the ones it's so backwards those are
the people that are on their [ __ ]
computers
scouring podcasts for tv show ideas that
they can sell
right but you can flip to netflix and i
should have listened to danny
that first night because here's what
happened i was working with someone
that continually kept saying don't do
anything on
your own because that could ruin the
deal that i'm working on right now i'm
working on this i'm working on that i'm
and he was what dumb ass told you that i
don't want to say his name but the point
is he knows who he is
so the point is when we are we're having
zoom meetings and we're having me
they're about to fly me out to la and
i've been out there
i've met with with these with production
companies and so things were happening
but it was always
don't do anything don't do anything
don't do just and you know i'm not even
sure about the podcast you going on that
concrete podcast
you know you talked you told your whole
story i'm like well there's a book out
why wouldn't
i like you know so i'm like i'm trying
to sell my book i have a book
yes snake oil salesman and he's going on
and on i mean he meant well but i'm
saying
you were right like the moment i started
going
yeah i'm not waiting anymore it's just
stupid
danny was telling me go just start doing
it just start doing i was like no no
no like if i just started at that point
i'd be a year
at least a year maybe a year and a half
ahead of where i am right now instead of
having like 30 000 subscribers on my
channel
i'd probably have a hundred thousand
subscribers i'd probably be paying all
my bills and
everything but i didn't kept waiting
because i kept waiting for like the
big hollywood deal
i might have said shopify whatever i
know tomato tomato so
yeah um